la nueva cepa del virus que causa kobe
19 sigue trayendo nuevas restricciones
para los vuelos de reino unido a los
países europeos que cerraron sus
fronteras con los británicos ahora se
suman por lo menos 5 países
latinoamericanos el primero en prohibir
el transporte aéreo fue el salvador
a partir de ahora queda prohibido el
ingreso a nuestro país de cualquier
persona que es vitín erario de vuelo
haya incluido el reino unido- sudáfrica
o que haya estado en alguno de esos dos
países en los últimos 30 días el
gobierno de colombia también suspendió
desde este lunes los vuelos desde y
hacia reino unido- y cualquier persona
que haya estado en suelo británico en
las últimas dos semanas deberá entrar en
cuarentena según el presidente iván
duque estas medidas de nuevo son de
prevención no son para generar ni pánico
ni generar ninguna situación de
preocupación en la ciudadanía en chile-
la restricción será más dura pues además
de cancelar todos los vuelos
provenientes del reino unido
también se prohibirá desde el martes y
por lo menos durante dos semanas la
entrada de cualquier extranjero que haya
estado en ese país mientras que a los
chilenos que hayan estado recientemente
en suelo británico se les impondrá una
cuarentena obligatoria de 14 días
argentina se suma a las prohibiciones y
sólo permitió aterrizar un vuelo que ya
estaba programado para hoy en el
aeropuerto internacional de ezeiza los
pasajeros y la tripulación tendrán una
cuarentena de una semana y perú no sólo
canceló todos los viajes desde reino
unido sino que además evalúan los vuelos
desde y hacia europa